he's an enemy of the state you want to
know the truth the enemy of the state is
him and the group that control him
[Music]
the fbi and the justice department have
become vicious monsters
controlled by radical left scoundrels
lawyers and the media who tell them what
to do you people right there and when to
do it
[Music]
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
[Music]
pennsylvania is incredibly important we
have an open senate seat in a midterm
election where only a handful of races
are even close and we have an open
gubernatorial seat where
whoever is going to win this race is
going to determine whether pennsylvania
is a pro-life or pro-choice state and so
because former president trump has
endorsed both republican candidates for
these offices he has some skin in this
game and president biden is from
pennsylvania so both see not only the
fact that pennsylvania is a battleground
but also that they have very personal
stakes here
[Music]
there was no mention of why he took the
controversial documents from the white
house in the first place why his lawyers
certified that they'd been returned when
the fbi search revealed that in fact
they hadn't so many questions remain
that were not answered within trump's
speech he also did not repeat the claim
that all these documents were
declassified something that has been
made in social media this is the type of
statement that the fbi would lean in to
should there be an investigation into
obstruction of justice
[Music]
you